Here's a guy whose mouth can sound like
an engine.
And this woman can be a human
car alarm.
But are those the best mouth noises
of all-time?
And better yet, what happened to my beard?
Well, to figure out the answer to this one,
you'll have to wait for 'The Key of Awesome's'
new music video on Thursday.
But don't let it distract you, ladies.
Let's focus on the mouth
and mouth noises and the best of all time.
All aboard the boat.
Here's an old man who can do a monkey and
a horse.
On the aquatic side, here's
a dolphin woman.
This guy can mimic the sound of a pistol reloading.
And if you want something wetter,
this kid opens and pours a can of coke.
When things get awkward, call over Fletcher901
who can give you some great cricket
noises to fill the silence.
Competitive whistelers
are incredible.
One of the neatest
whistle tricks I've seen is the ability
to whistle through two or more
openings in your mouth, so you can make
multiple tones and harmonize
with yourself.
Of course, beat boxers are some of the most famous
noisemakers on YouTube.
Some newer clips
show beat boxers during dub step sounds,
like Reeps One.
Links, by the way, to all these noises are in
the description below.
Also worth a listen is Mastamicbeatbox.
And Slizzer.
I mean, look how much fun this guy's having.
While you're jamming to that, I wanna
invite you into my own little
experiment. On Thursday, the next Vsauce video
on this channel will come out at
exactly
6 p.m. Eastern.
The first 100 people to get there and comment the word
"Boooyerz" will get a YouTube message specially
from me.
So you have to be there right at 6 p.m.
Let's see what happens.
And as always,
thanks for watching.